good evening everyone welcome to our
first it's my first lecture about pound
moves I don't know how exactly should I
name it
what's name exactly my day
anyways I always talk about evaluation I
love talking about evaluation why do I
care about evaluation because we are not
machines there are human will make them
sticks we cannot see everything that's
why we need to have a grasp and
evaluation of what is going on on the
board to do so you need to evaluate so
to evaluate what you need for knowing
what's going on in every situation you
need a measurement and it's not to tell
you what is going on on the board so for
that you come up with criteria number of
criteria here and there one of the most
important criteria that I want to talk
about tonight
are pawns pawn instructors and pawn
moves they can be extremely simple
extremely mysterious well options
extremely mysterious and sometimes very
subtle and sometimes very deadly for you
for you but first thing when you see a
pawn your opponent's pawn what should
you think about take it exactly
have you been to Esther's classes no
well that's what he also said I was just
you know as a grandmaster 2/3 of my
career was all about grabbing pants yeah
that's my career grabbing pawns but
really if you see a loose ball try to
grab it you know we talked about
quarantine apiece you know trapping a
piece or just out play a piece but you
see pawn you grab it no no no doubt
about that but a very important thing
okay joke aside a very important thing
is that pawns main job is to control
weakest course and protect critical in
our position so one of the use of of
pawns is to create an - to control Vicki
scores let's start with this position
this is black to move as you can see
given the initial pawn was in a game
another thing okay when you talk about
pawns you cannot just start talking
without mentioning the famous Russian
proverb upon pushes upon that never goes
back that's means once you push upon the
score next to it becomes weak it means
the under undermined because it doesn't
control it anymore so as you can see
given all the pawn moves happens so far
in this game we see a lot of weakest
scores let's name some of them in both
white and black position let's just our
vice position some weak is closing
White's position here before you see
what score you see black dark-squared
that we can use in White's camp what
else d 4 I can't take that yeah but I
can use Square D 4 - what else you know
that punim bit wood ok h3 this is square
or f3 okay this bishop is taking a good
care of both right so do you think these
two scores could be undermined we could
be attacked you hmm you have access to
these scores as black so a weakness like
always talked about is that but nice
move but if you look at blacks position
these two scores they look weak too I'm
just using different color are they weak
or not they look
because Queen covers okay now the
question is that h6 is weak do I have
access to it does black have does white
have access to the h-60 square then is
the weakness my favorite sentence when I
whenever I teaches if Vicki scores a
weakness is something can exploit if you
have no access to it it's not the
weakness so the darkest scores are
potential weaknesses but I cannot use it
right now if black if white gets to play
F 4 e 5 then the knight comes to e4 and
goes to have 6 10 yes we have to be
worried about or dark scores yet that so
it's a potential for a weakness but it's
not an immediate weakness make sense
good ok now let's look at okay I just
drew way too many arrows and stuff here
let's get rid of these okay so these are
not weaknesses that I'm gonna just get
rid of them so before was this week a
squared d3 we can use it with a bishop
is not on f1 or e2 to cover it so d3 is
another score to use the c-4 score
itself is a weakness if I if my bishop
would have access to this Black's Bishop
and c5 score of course we can use it
because if I put in either on c5 and
played b6 I have a very outstanding
I have a very beautifully placed an
outstanding night on c5 that you can
touch it so now
now speaking of all of these is there
any other weaknesses in Black's camp d5
and b5 no I mean I can try to use these
two scores huh okay that tells you what
should be blacksmithing right
mmm-hmm no questions
now you can also play Bishop e6 first
which one Bishop e6 or c6 doesn't matter
up to d4
that's um oh yeah we'll go back
I mean this this plan is now coming a 45
night house here right so then well c6
takes care of everything right
controlled both the scores the point is
that after oops
after we should be six I have this move
Queen B five black is still better with
correct with correct tactical play who I
can get advantage with 95 or just Queens
aside with Queen c5 actual Bitcoin c5 I
cannot take because of this trap but
nevertheless it's not as clear c6
because after c6 we have immediate plan
we shall come to mission comes to e6 not
goes to before we know where where do
our pieces are going so after c6 so this
is a preventive pawn move so so the
first use of a part is to control Vicki
scores c6 f 4 okay what about therefore
take your time this is a very important
calculation based position now after c6
we don't have a problem with Queen to b5
now answer the threat with a stronger
threat
Quincy five check I can take and then
Luke t1e five yours may be slightly
better but that's it
you have partly five I have I have three
as way too many attackers right okay how
about attack with development perfect
Bishop to e6 now if I go Queen e2 what
happens answer a threat which is
stronger for it
Queen to c5 chicken why now c5 check if
I go king each one what happens Bishop
to c4 now right very nice a skewer and
if I go Queen f2 look T to Queen takes
Knight takes rook F to I think you can
take take oops I update I'm this check
and take on b2 is also possible but it's
not as surprisingly isn't as clear as it
seems so I check check with the engine
that was my initial idea but I check
with an engineer it says look it is
better and the reason is that those
witnesses are kind of stuff are still
there and we have this beautiful
maneuver Rock t4 rock before or up t2 we
have this square the bishop goes to see
for way too many good things and while
it's kind of paralyzed so that did not
happen in the game white plays rook F to
d1 o Bishop g4 was better some missing
with a voice pawn structure first f3 and
then drop back right okay nevertheless P
should be six there Bishop d3 another
nine square because of that a4 if that
part if what could have played if I were
to move back any of my pawns I could I
will just play a four back to a two that
were looking stronger than they will
finger piece or a two back 283 just to
cover before as well I thought a for
back to a3 so
the one it should be 610 Bishop III rock
T to look T for now we used d4 square
now we used to double the roof from
bring into the game to through d8 as you
can see
black is exploiting every single vehicle
scoring-wise position whereas white
after c6 cannot use any of the week
supposed to the biggest scores in blacks
camp doesn't make sense 595 and here it
blundered losing upon and that was it
this is the game was a game between
donor you are young donor and Smith Slav
okay questions so far
okay so far so good which moment now at
this moment well therefore I just can't
give a check and then trade and I have a
winning endgame again well three games
to a4 is always week there who comes to
d8 and there's a much to be done
okay now this one
I don't need this opening so I'm just
starting from the position I care for
okay this is the position I want to
discuss with you guys
same thing covering Vicky's scores and
also pawns are not only used I mean they
they have a lot of defensive values of
course they not only use a shield or or
covering weak scores they can also be
used as undermining power underlying
powers like undermining your opponent's
pawn structure and covering like sitting
on a weaker square when did when they
are on a weaker square they get you when
you push them they may be weakened
because when you push upon it gets
closer to opponent's camp however when
you push upon you also gain space so you
can use the space behind the pawn to
support and actually control Vicky's
scores sometimes pushing a pawn is just
a pre-emptive act I cannot believe I use
that force okay now here white here
black to move f6 okay what else Bishop
takes c4 this Bishop is a very beautiful
piece right do you like to give up your
beautiful things like hmm okay
well I have enough cover for it right
well I would do that for upon as I told
you the first rule it was what grabs
upon that was number rule number one
right so if the night goes to this is I
take the pawn takes you take with a
queen it will be up upon I know you may
love your Bishop on e7 but I love to
grab a farm or we always have to grab
upon always always
a5 exactly with X clamp because this is
score is kind of weak because I the
bishop can watch wants to play move like
Bishop a5 292 or have three kind of
controlling a lot of scores here on the
other hand I'm sorry black has what pair
of bishop when you're a pair of bishop
you would like to open the game so a5
not only covers the square I intend to
play a four get rid of my isolated pawn
trade and make b3 business so black
if so Bishop c3 and I want to double
take on b3 claim comes to b7 like this
slightly better soon
all right so a five a four now after a
four now this is very important this
pawn is fixed but this point is also
fixed so these two are V so white fixed
a 5 we can undermine oil obviously on
the right fix the weakness on a 5 what
give give away the because I'm b3 so
there isn't much we can do now with the
with the pawns right all locked
it's about it's time for peace play
look fp8 look b1 and then the question
is that you have to ask yourself what's
your worst piecing in this position
because since the pollen structure is
kind of locked now is it locked it's
fixed because the pond structure is
fixed it's time to you can actually
think about envision the position you
want for each piece you have enough time
because there's no immediate assault
going on in the position ninety-eight
fantastic very good move now it goes to
c6 covers a five the other who comes to
p8 because do you want to defend this
pawn on f5 with the rock or be denied
why the rule of minimum energy
I call it how much does a rock worth
five a night he wanted to use less meat
material to defend a weakness so better
to use a 90 defend and also the knight
has some future now but the night on d7
has no future
excellent move 98 key 196 Bishop c3 rook
b8 there okay great fantastic regrouping
for black right now I'm preparing to
jump with my nighttime before at some
point
Queenie one night before and here white
blunders queen e3 how they give it to
you what this one watch is AB London
actually late night 52 and Black has
some pressure but you cannot really see
something very concrete for blacks
advantage maybe some h6 then Bishop g5
black should be better maybe maybe even
the sort of maneuver just try to force
the palm of White's camp in White's camp
but I I couldn't see any concrete
continuation for for what for black but
black is that black is definitely better
so Queen III is a mistake
so we accumulated everything we could
The Critic because my spine structure we
already had a weakness remember when our
pawns were on a six and c5
they're already disintegrated they were
isolated so they were already weak but
by pushing a five before stay for
undermine the White has a weak point on
b3 on the other hand the managed
maneuver the night before which
previously couldn't just land there
easily because what clubs like maybe a 2
a 3 but because of a for now the night
is comfortably sitting on b4 now okay
well take your time first of all and see
if you can now grab upon so we started
with a good point move improving our
pieces position on its time about the
most important act grabbing the part
it's a form of calculation now you don't
you don't affect the policy for from a3
you don't want to put your night over
there on the edge of the board because
this after this and I see - I just go
right not a three I can just go Queen
you're trapping your night
I'm have to take on b8 obviously I don't
want to give up my rook okay Bishop c4 b
takes c4 well when you want to grab from
you have to attack the power right
Oh actually I have to include this first
now there's not okay one because of
night c2 and the opponent before is as
falling after h4h six king h2 and I
played okay eight before I take on a for
a plural k-8 there there and then black
grabs the pawn and gradually wins this
game actually this is maybe another
Argentine player mine field Nick feel
like yes okay today we have the
Argentinian theme huh black was her my
pillow making this game okay next game
I've saved so many of these games
the other value of Ponk pushes to
address weaknesses or create the
possibility for pieces to to activate
with a pawn push you can open the file
you can open a diagonal so all you can
reinforce an outpost so with your panels
you can you can help your pieces to show
higher quality throughout the game or at
some moment if a bad wish of trapped in
your pawn structure get out and and be a
become active but with the pump will
open the file that you're in active
route get into the game or create an
attack with your with your look longer
usually like you push the edge spawn
then you have a look on each one and
there's opponent g6 to open the H file
and and deliver checkmate
so CD for CD 495 this is a this is sort
of an old game between Nigel short and
Bourgogne the firewalk onion from
armenia special goes back g3 we should
be seven c8 here Bishop takes f5
probably most like h4 or we should be to
work we're better but ok p3 and Bishop
35 now let's look at this position who
has better development black right black
is developed controls the C file has
some pressure long over voice Center on
d4 he has a weaker pawn structure right
because of the double pawn and the weak
pawn on d5 I would say big but it's
another the pawn on d5 and very
importantly that the bishop on d7
doesn't do much at this moment right so
given that what should be the
continuation for white for black sorry
to actually take advantage of White's
lack of development and I'm actually
open the game
we are heading developments right so we
need what an open position or a closed
position so then then we can take
advantage of or extra piece activity
[Music]
which we move the night with those are
bishop
go ahead f6 interesting I'll have six I
can take take that yes you exchanged
some pieces but do you actually get an
open open file or diagonal f4 right away
or first Bishop takes Bishop Bishop
takes Knight X then F for now the bishop
wants to sit on a5 the knight wants to
come to e7 and look at this all of a
sudden I have an attacking it against
White's King if I don't take the bishops
it's on the five didn't take on c2 I win
the d4 pawn
all of a sudden White's position is
critical 97 now I want to transfer the
Queen to g6 Knight e3 and now what this
is a very important moment in the same
not g6 I'm attacking a pawn on f4
because f4 not only open the files open
opened a lot of diagonals for the bishop
on d7 also undermine White's King and
and created the beacons on therefore for
white
now can you defend the pawn can you
defend the pawn on f4 how it's going
after a good move no there's neither
short check not for this lecture always
watched watch the force always watch the
forks
okay how about Kim g3 that is a very
bold King
this is a good one give it some time
this is a very interesting one
ix except for right the sacrifice see
what happens I wasn't just sure about
this queen of three we can just go night
here and if it takes just take Queen 64
okay I just for a second I didn't see
this okay let me explain to you why this
is losing because I said this one coming
and now again another part move f6 f6
opening the file and now the king is
completely exposed in the center game
will be decided soon so we can look at
some most like tonight back check the
King runs away but it's too late I saw
this continuation when I when I was
thinking about Queen f3 I couldn't see
it before it's hanging after that so
that's why so I can I use my King so
immediately the attack is is coming in
place and so what's happening here after
this night after is okay play he made
him sick knowledge e6 and black is
winning three moves Bishop g5 f 497 came
over Palmas could be very very very
dangerous and instructive okay so so far
what kind of uses about palmistry we've
enumerated we have we have addressed
okay let's go from the very first game
we learned that the past could cover
what pika scores right that was the
first thing we learned was from the
second game what did we learn
pushing the pawns to gain space and
cover the biggest square sometimes but
because you are pushing to create
weaknesses in your plans your opponent
has to give businesses in return so as
you give that weakness your opponent
also has to give one so you kind of get
rid of your weakness by creating one for
your opponent and fixing the pawn
structure because hmm I don't think that
finds important actually well let's just
stick to the pushing to open the file
okay
and this game what did we learn with the
pawn push this was very very nice lesson
this one opened a gallant why you got a
unique piece exactly attack you need an
open game so you can use pawn push to
open the game usually comes as a
sacrifice or a pseudo sacrifice
questions so far
good okay now let's go over a
masterpiece that has been played last
year between vistas so and fado CF
unless the soul was as high as number
two in the world and is in the top ten
and there's a Content that this US
Championship that is going on he's tied
for second he's he's actually the
defending champion and it's from the
last year's World Cup in Georgia against
the Russians newest hope fedosya is like
20 years old few years younger than so
so we see okay you don't know this
opening Petrov or Russian defense so
it relies okay this is from my older
than old analysis this is also an
interesting look to be played different
palm push but we still haven't gotten
there so 92 Bishop f5 okey one night XT
to have to take obviously with a queen
here okay there's a small fact that you
have to see if Bishop takes a five and I
takes a three we cannot take here
because of 90 XT for that's a problem so
that's why I taking on the [ __ ] doesn't
work so I take with a queen which it
takes d3
okay now let's sit back and look at this
position how many open files are are
there in this game one how is the point
structure fixed not fixed is it fixed is
it locked or not do you expect any
activity on either side of the board in
terms of point structure or pawn moves
you do maybe if that bishop would leave
a7 then you may play h4 h5 getting some
space and trying to attack with 95
because although there are not that much
material left in terms of minor pieces
for attack for an attack that 95 could
become dangerous because black doesn't
have a knight on f6 to cover his castle
so what plan is actually very simple
this is a position actually happened in
a game beat the first game ever played
between carpet on Kasparov Karpov was
the world champion at the time was is it
is it that the game is it a saml game i
don't think it's the sound okay no it's
not but this i think this is their first
game that is face to face and it's not a
similar or something like that it's a
when Kasparov was actually is on his way
to become world champion so 27 the ship
before the plan is very simple okay
froakie 8 then you just like win b5 is
obviously very irritating annoying move
but it's not as clear that how we can
I think I just left it there that means
that it's not clear that how we can what
they can do after op8
apparently what's that I can grab the
pole
I forgot the file on b7 c7 c7 is hanging
right so low-key to simple as that so
it's the official six and then we
control the open file and in Kasparov
scam and Kasparov scam he came up with
the very nice idea midnight 92 91 and 93
the Queen goes to f3 attacking the pawn
on d5 I think I have a somewhere here
let me a little bit west the player
rookie 2 rookies 3 play by Kasparov H 3
and after takes rook takes f6 here I
came up with rookie - okay f7 and then
he played 92 and 94 93 regrouping the
pieces white has a constant pressure
blacks two pieces are passive minor
pieces and white minor pieces are active
and later on in this game came a very
very bad blunder by
Karpov and now we should take c7 and if
you leave your computer the engine
running for a while it shows a huge
advantage for white but somehow Kasparov
I don't know got a little bit too
excited for for his first win against
world champion or any other reason the
game he'll collect coffees advantage in
the game ended in a draw okay Rocky - we
don't need meditation
back ok yeah it ok e1 bishop did we are
still following the same pattern 92
right now that goes to F 1 and e3 and
the point here is that this what's the
improvement of 90 rookie to the Luke is
not on III so I don't need to drop the
rock back remember do you remember
comfort the game cuz part of Karpov the
rook drop back to 2001 tempo now I just
play the same rookie to Queen e2 that
goes to a fun 93 also I also have the
idea of going on Knight to b3 and trying
to go to c5 if black plays be 16 you can
take on a 6 so that's also another plan
okay Knight is seven was the way to
fight for equality 93 there Knight c5
and Bishop back to G 3 which should be 7
and black gradually brings the pieces to
the game most like this was the best way
to make a draw or trying to but it's a
long-term suffering what that's the best
way probably by black who played so a 5
so we talked about good pawn moves let's
talk about a responsible promise why if
I was not a good let's try to sit back
and try to understand why a 5 is not a
good move
if we can simplify were very important
and we are pushing remember about the
pawns always put your pawns and the
color opposite of your bishop the one
you have and put your opponent's pawn
try to make your opponent's pawn to be
on the same color view of your Bishop so
you can attack them so here to make a
for a target as it turns out at the end
not really that important but I'm
nothing black lost because of this move
but as it turns out at the end this
becomes a very fatal and decisive
squirtle squad as we will get there so
after a 593 nice trying to get the 93
that's I mean the idea so b6 so now as
you can see that Bishop 28 is not doing
so great does it it doesn't so great and
our Bishop has a target keeps attacking
those pawns you can say okay I can do
your pawns on b2 c3 and before also of
the same color of the of your Bishop but
my bishop is out of that kind of chain
is not stucked it's not stuck there so I
see one f6
a for is it a good pawn well I fix
that's a good panel I fixed the pawn
structure if I play b3 later my pawns
are in light squares black spawns are in
dark scores and they're kind of stuck 97
93 g5 okay tada safe is a very
aggressive player he's not used to long
term defending and then he's become
impatient is the good panel but
surprisingly it's not bad but no don't
do this mobs now there's a second target
blocking is a little bit undermined and
either f4 or h4 and some other moves
like that could create more witnesses in
blacks position so
and I worked with d3 and Blackley Bishop
e7 so so far
white has played harmless pornos and
black has played provocative pawn moves
right as we talked about the very early
on in the class upon pushes upon that
never goes back okay now let's see if
you can you can find this brilliant idea
that gives probably a winning position
to black to white this is one move with
the tactical flavor
well I was a tactical flavor is some
small cheapo destroys black's pawn
structure and we get a winning end game
the bishop and insert hanging is the key
but the move is not therefore its search
for well because this fire is coming and
after G takes search for not this is
first of all look at this pass complete
it is integrated become with one move
white completely storage black's pawn
structure on the on the kingside now
before this at this moment we have sort
of a [ __ ] [ __ ] but still the
punching all three are chained together
after h4 look at all these three points
suddenly you have three targets in the
endgame and here comes the next
important mode well that's the endgame
that means less pieces on the board that
means I lacked Knight f4 I want to trade
pieces ok of 726 1 I go for the endgame
now the d5 is the target right the
knight and the Queen are attacking d5 so
this trade is happening this is still
hanging we like endgame and this
position on the board as you can see
black is up upon but white is winning
well first of all the pawn on c7 is
hanging Bishop d8 here comes the next
and the final important pawn move
okay and then you play before if I take
on before what happens okay before a sip
or then
or c4 well right now before it seems to
be having a love strong argument in
favor of it you want c4 why
another use of the second user since the
first thing you see a pond and grabbed
upon the second thing is that if you
have a pond pushed upon in the endgame
try to get the passport so b4 is the
move the point is if I take I take who's
going to stop this this pond trying to
comma Queen honest a BOGO so before
black has to play this King g7 but now
we take take and we go after the pond
that's a very valuable pantograph grab
because this three against two again is
completely crippled and these pawns are
following one after the other I have a
very active rook so that control of if
I'll came very handy and became very
crucial that's what kind of seven
doesn't do anything with a token Isis is
the is the boss c6 rook takes c6 king g6
rook c5 octi 7 f3 is controlling some
squares not letting this King
marching all the way here and then here
so just controlling everything can get 5
Bishop b2 King g6 Rock c6 check King a
5k playing few moves here and there and
what is in complete control
well black has blocking Profis panel now
from 6 to 4
it is a still on target so it's still a
target so if you if you push your
weakness and if you cannot liquidate it
it's just a weakness and it's actually
worse weakness because now it's in
White's camp I can grab it
now what you do
so what was what changes have happened
here okay here comes a very important
decision what changes have happened so
far what puts his king on a three fixed
all these pawns black doesn't have a
single pawn Singh and black doesn't have
even a pair of ponder that they defend
each other all of them on an island
they're all isolated whereas why has
this healthy pause see 3d for f3 chief G
- exactly
well he didn't he can do it as at any
moment he was and finally did it
now enough of pawns the stock a little
of endgame strategy to wrap up the class
now what's the winning plan here well
when one plays c4 then you bring the
king my king would be waiting for you
the bishop is defending so we we take we
take our time okay first bishop on e1
when you want to move the King on d3 you
have to make sure that doesn't have h3
king gauge for that's the first step now
the second step now how do we win this
c5 I just stay with my king you lock the
position then followed by
I need to get my Bishop as we talked we
pushed the pawns
such that we can get a bishop outside of
the chain exact Thank You bishop there
it should be to a little bit of okay now
this is a this is a six block as you can
see h5 same maneuver no bishop goes back
to close to eight get another Bishop is
outside that will change now not this
Bishop is out of move this is a
completely other move now okay and most
importantly you need to have patience
that's very important yeah very
important and then Bishop and earnest
now this is game over
very beautiful game I don't be
encouraged to covert this game and I
wish I could talk about a lot of parts
of it in details but I want to use it
for another class too as well so if you
guys come in for da and for the end game
and the surgery play we'll talk about
them over there too
[Music]